I would be remiss if I didn't mention
you have had the chance to play one one
of the all-time great conservative
characters
The Gipper yes
I lived in Los Angeles for seven years
and somehow I see more movie stars more
frequently since I've moved to Tennessee
than I ever did in California including
my neighbor
the great Dennis Quaid
yes different neighborhood but yes we
are neighbors pretty pretty close we're
all here in the great state of Tennessee
and you're making movies all over the
place including in the great state of
Texas yes and I have to ask are people
making movies in Hollywood anymore or no
they're all going everywhere else I
think they still do their game shows
there and Housewives shows but uh now uh
they're not it's uh Texas is my home
state and I moved out to
California in the 70s it was fantastic
it was a great place to be and live and
uh but if I was a young actor right now
today I think I'd moved to Atlanta
because that's where the parts would be
you know if you're
and that's where the business a lot of
so much business is being done because
they have such a great incentive program
and so you're working right now you
mentioned you're from the great state of
Texas for me I I All My Exes Live in
Texas so I hang my hat in Tennessee
obviously but a lot of people are going
to Texas and uh if you have it your way
a lot more people who are making movies
are going to be going to Texas because
yeah we used to have a really great
incentive program in uh in Texas and I I
made quite a few movies there I made the
rookie there uh DOA
it's I've done about four or five movies
there and uh I actually sorry to
interrupt you I didn't realize you made
that movie there and I was thinking I
was like what's my favorite Dennis Quaid
movie I freaking love the rookie that is
interesting and it's a Texas story too
yeah I didn't know the Alamo we did that
there but uh
thank God we did the Alamo in Texas but
uh about seven years ago
um seven or eight years ago the
you know some people were led to believe
you know voters that it they started to
look on it as a Hollywood giveaway yeah
really and a lot of the business started
moving out of state and a lot of crew
who worked they had a great Carew Base
in Texas you know because you need crew
to make movies and uh they moved to
Louisiana or or uh New Mexico now
Oklahoma
as uh is got a great incentive program
and Texas is surrounded by all this and
of course Georgia and they'd get up you
know it's it's roughly about 30 percent
out of the uh taxes that they uh they
get 30 of the money they spend in the
state
there they get back right you know but
they have those states have income tax
where's Texas doesn't so it's it's a
tough Hill to climb but it's
uh still Texas can do it they have a 35
million dollar Surplus and it's time for
film to come back to Texas and and build
an industry that's not just subsidized
by the by uh the taxpayers is it
taxpayers but it you know it you invest
in it and for every dollar that is it
um
put in it produces five come out of it
because the money's spit in the state
yet by the by the film companies in
hotels
and uh you know salaries for crew that
live there and things like that
restaurants and that's that's really
where the bunnies spend it's it's a lot
of people thought that it goes it's a
big Hollywood giveaway and it goes to
producers and you know big highly paid
Hollywood actors like me but uh I'm
already getting paid anyway I get paid
no matter where you get shot if it's in
California yeah they call that below the
line everything you know that's uh not
the actors basically is below the line
and that's the actual money to
for any cameras for paying for crew to
put people up in hotels and uh and the
like and um
it's carpenters and electricians and
yeah uh movie movie uh sets they're
actually really kind of industrial sites
right right so you know
there's an interesting comparison to be
made with people going to California you
know you think California gets settled
really during the gold rush and but but
then you wonder okay who who really
strikes it big to you know pull that
money out is it the people going and
finding well that's a really good
analogy to it because you
that's what this program you know the
incentive program is basically uh
does you know people who went to
California during the Gold Rush a few of
them did strike it rich but it was the
people who were selling shovels and who
had hotels and you know people up in
bars they were the ones who really made
the money uh for the most part you know
and that stayed in the state too was it
taken back to St Louis or wherever they
came from and that's where the incentive
program is like because if you get
people coming in you're going to build
in a street you're going to have a lot
of these group people coming back uh
to uh to taxes and uh you know that's
right right there you're going to have a
revenue that comes into the state in the
business you look at the uh tech
industry
um around Austin
you know uh Texas really has taken its
share as far as Tech from California
so because it's is it's more business
friendly right so it was made more
business friendly for Tech and I want
the same thing that for for film that
that that's my broader political
question here I guess is
why is it that so many people now are
looking to make movies outside of
Hollywood outside of California what
does it mean for the kind of broader
business and political landscape because
it's cost you much money yeah you know
and uh you have all these rules you know
you can't just get a street in uh in a
Hollywood or
you know West Side residential area you
got all these regulations and much more
money you've got to spend and you know
you're restricted how long you can shoot
if you go to we we were I'm doing a
Taylor Sheridan Western in Texas right
now who is doing great things down there
uh about bringing Texas film back
uh we had we took over the town of
Stephenville you know it's just like 5
000 people are in this town and they got
12 million dollars injected into their
economy in a two-week period I mean
that's
you know that's into that economy that
little little microcosm there and that
that goes a long way it really does well
especially when you know the money is
injected and then if most of the people
then just kind of go home you know so
they leave leave the money there and
yeah you know either you move on to the
next yeah it's not like we're asking
people to uh invest in movies I mean
it's way too risky because I don't know
what Maniac whatever I'll do them but uh
I'm going to invest in them you know
it's uh it's just it's just uh about the
bunny that comes in is that what the
beard is about is that for this role
yeah
I think there are a lot of reasons I
can't play a cool old grizzled Texas guy
but one of them is I can't grow the
beard I don't I don't think have you
ever really tried I've never given
myself really tried it's only ever been
two weeks at most about three weeks
would tell you that okay all right well
maybe listen Dennis will I have
obviously missed my shot at being on
this movie but maybe I'll give it three
weeks
darn all right well if they pass the
incentives program in Texas maybe I'll
have a shot for the next one yeah but
right now right now there's a
legislation that in uh at the state
house I went there about I went to state
house about a month and a half ago on an
on another bill which is about the
electrical grid but uh
visited uh the Senate the the speaker of
the house and the attorney general and
the governor and the governor asked me
to get involved with this because he's
really for it and uh the legislation is
there they want to increase the
uh the fund for the film incentive from
40 million which it is right now to like
300 billion which would be significant
wow and a great start and it'll be good
because uh I think once that done once
that done that 300 million
could become you know 1.5 billion if one
dollar in five dollars out
and uh
so this is the end of the legislative
session and we're asking people to
call their state reps or senators and
let's make Texas the film capital of the
world so Dennis is this a one-man
crusade to bring movies back to Texas uh
nobody talked to the governor and that
we had this legislation coming up but we
wanted to get the word out and you know
I'm not the only actor that's who is you
know complained about this and because
we all want to work in Texas all these
guys who were from Texas and so my first
call was Billy Bob Thornton who is not
from Texas but he played Davey Crockett
so that he seems like he could be it
like yeah they're called Matthew
McConaughey he lives in Austin you know
Glenn Powell who's in Top Gun uh Woody
Harrelson
text in there and Owen Wilson as well
and Owen Wilson's attacks him Edward
Wilson is from uh Dallas Fort Worth area
he and his brother Luke and uh
you know we uh wrote a script up in in a
couple of days and then got a director
we went to wherever
everybody was and
shot the script and put it out and when
we get people riled up that's great now
if people are riled up what can they do
is there a website they go to is there a
yeah it's hashtag good for taxes if you
just type that in Okay Google or yeah
the video that we made is out right now
in fact you can find it on YouTube and
we're gonna do a social media blitz and
doing shows like this to get uh to get
the word out good for Texas and the and
the usual I guess not call your
Congressman because it's a state issue
but call your State Rep call your
Governor or that sort of campaign there
is at the uh on you go to good for taxes
and it uh will tell Texans just exactly
how to do that how to find your own
State Rep if you don't know who that is
you know just type in your
your area code there and your ZIP code I
mean and uh
we'll find them great all right they can
all do that then we can all head down to
Texas and if I can grow a beard maybe
I'll audition for the movie
okay well consider it I would be remiss
if I didn't mention you have had the
chance to play one one of the all-time
great conservative characters The Gipper
yes I have
well Reagan is coming out uh which we
shot in Oklahoma by the way
taxes
but uh
Reagan is coming out uh at the end of
this year I can't I've been so excited
through everything you know for a loop
and yeah I've been so excited since the
first time I heard about this movie I
think it was at the California Club
maybe it was the first time I heard you
talk about this movie for one of the
Reagan dinners and yeah I can't I can't
wait for it that's a great organization
it is a lot of fun yeah so that'll be
that'll be wonderful and then who knows
maybe we'll get some more uh more great
conservative content down there too yeah
maybe yeah well will it will trust but
verify thank you Dennis thank you for
being here appreciate it and best of
luck on the campaign we will see you
next time either in Tennessee or Texas
or somewhere else on the interwebs
[Music]